happens in the UK and I haven't seen
this just from the perspective of the
health secretary but as Chancellor as
well is that when at any chance that
when they're allocating uh funding of
course there's many other trade-offs to
be made what about education what about
defense costs are going up interest
rates that are going up so inevitably
there's trade-offs and a Chancellor will
look at the biggest budget in in
government the NHS and in every the NHS
will have to be a consequence of that
trade-off so it the the to avoid that to
some extent you I think having a look at
other models of care and how they're
funded is is the right thing uh to do
but also uh you look at the overall
funding is to realize that it's not a
question of funding in the other
countries with less funding seem to be
getting better outcomes so you have to
look at the model and you have to look
at the aspects of healthcare